Man: Engineers at Airbnb,
particularly this really nice
JavaScript style guide, that
shows you how to write ES6 in a
way that is consistent across
all of your projects. It does
things like it tells you to use
const and when to use let and
how to write your if statements
and where do you semicolons and
etc., all that information, and
the ESLint file is sort of the
enforcement of this actual style
guide. What a lot of people
do, is they adapt the Airbnb
style of coding and then they'll
sort of just use their own
settings on top of it, and
that's exactly what we're going
to do here today. We're going to
implement the Airbnb style guide
and then we're going to sort of
go through in and pick off
little things where we believe
that our style differs a little
bit. Go to github.com/airbnb/
JavaScript click on packages,
click on eslint-config-airbnb
and it's going to show us
how it actually works. To
install someone else's style
guide you can go to your
eslintrc and instead of
extending the ESLint recommended
we're going to extend the Airbnb,
and I'm going to show you what
happens if we just change that.
Go back to our console here and
run ESLint against it, it's
going to give us an error here
cannot find module eslint-config-
airbnb, why can't we do that?
Because we haven't yet actually
installed it. Now, you can
install this locally to your
project if you only need it on
one project. But since, I like
to use it on every single
project that I'm working on I
like to install it globally.
Now, there's some install
instructions right here and what
I like to tell people do is just
go ahead and copy those install
instructions and paste them into
here. Then there's a few things
that's going to install ESLint
for us, we already have that, we
don't need it. We need the
accessibility JSX plugin. If you
aren't writing React you still
need to install that just
because all of these things here
were called pure dependencies
for ESLint and it needs to have
them all installed for us. We
get eslint-airbnb-config, we get
the import plugin, we get the
React in the JSX accessibility
one. Next, we want to install
this globally so change --save-
dev to -g and go ahead and just
copy and paste that right into
your terminal here. Again, if
you are running the computer
where you've not yet fixed your
npm you might have to type
pseudo and then paste in npm-
install. It's going to ask for
your password. You can type it
in, you won't see anything but
it will work and then just give
it a second while it goes ahead
and installs all of these
elements. If that has worked
properly we should now be able
to ESLint bad code and it's
going to tell us all kinds of
new errors that have been
happening with our actual code
right here. Let's go through a
couple. First of all there are a
whole bunch of errors that have
to do with spacing, a space is
required. Those are just such
minor little things that ESLint
will actually fix them
immediately for you. Right
here I have this space where I
shouldn't have done it and I
could go one by one and fix them
all. However, ESLint provides a --
fix option. You can say ESLint
bad code--fix and what it does…
See? It went from 12 problems
down to 2 problems, I go back to
this code and you see that it
just refreshed itself there.
It's going to fix almost all of
those little spacing issues for
us. Now we've got two other
problems here that are actually
running. First of all
unexpected var use let or const
instead, that's on line one,
let's go back up here. I'm
looking at this, I said var
whether = new Promise, so I'm
not going to be using var,
should I use let or should I use
const? Now the question here is
will I ever reassign whether,
does it need to update itself or
is it always going to hold this
whether promise? In the case
of us we're always going to be
holding the whether promise so
we use const, good, and we give
that a save and rerun it. One
more error, unaccepted block
statement surrounding arrow body
and this is the arrow-body-style.
It may not actually know like
what is the problem here, let's
go check it out. Line 25 it's
telling us unexpected block,
that's this thing right here
surrounding arrow-body-style, it
actually doesn't tell us what
the issue is. The issue with
here is that we have a block
statement and then all that
block is doing is returning.
What it actually should be
telling is that you should use
the implicit return if all that
you're going to be doing is
opening up a block and returning
one thing from it. Let's go
look at arrow-body-style -- read
the docs here. Arrow functions
have two formats. They may be
defined with a block or it's a
single expression, so it shows
us some examples of when you
wouldn't want to do it and when
you would want to use it. OK,
interesting. I like that error,
so I'm going to not turn it off
in here but I'm going to
actually go ahead and fix that
myself. We don't need a block
here, we don't need this return,
we don't need the opening block.
Now, this is going to
immediately return promises.all,
give that a save, now we'll run
back to our terminal and rerun
ESLint, and it should like
celebrate or something and tell
you that you did a good job but
it's simply just like "Yeah, of
course, you did a good job."
It's working for us, there we go.
So far we've been working with
the local.eslintrc file and that
means that we have an ESLint
file for every single project
that we work on. That can be
really handy when you have
different coding styles amongst
different projects or different
teams that you work with.
However, it's also helpful to
have a global eslintrc file,
which if you do not have an
ESLint file present anywhere
inside of your project, it's
going to use your global one as
sort of a default. I really
like to do that so I don't have
to create an ESLint file for
every single project or I have
one that I can copy/paste into
new projects that I'm going to
put up to GitHub and expect
others to follow that coding
style. I'm going to open up my
global one and it lives in your
home directory. What's your
home directory? Your home
directory is tilde, and that is
your folder by your username on
your computer, and in Windows is
going to be under C, users and
then your username. If you do
not have one you can do
touchtilde/.eslintrc, if you
already do have one you can just
open it up in your editor and…
I'm going to show you exactly
what is inside of mine. I've
been extending Airbnb just like
we have in here, I've work in
the browser node and sometimes I
use jQuery so I've turned all of
those on then I have all of
these rules that I have been
working with. Now, I take all
the rules from Airbnb and then
these are the ones where I don't
necessarily agree a hundred
percent with Airbnb's
implementation so these are just
the once that I've sort of taken
over. Let's take a look at
one comma- dangle. I've turned
that off, if I write some code
right here and I'd say like
const west=open up an object and
I say age is 100, and cool, is
true, and I give that a save and
let's try the ESLint, our bad
code again. It's going to yell
us. A whole bunch of stuff,
first of all, no-unused-vars,
that's good because I've created
a variable and haven't yet used
that. That's actually one
that I have turned to a warning
in my regular ESLint right here,
no-unused-vars because I say, "
Yeah, I should know when I don't
use a var but often I'm coding
and like I'm not done my
application yet and it's already
yelling at me for my errors."
What I would do is I turn that
to an actual warning. Let me
head to my local ESLint here,
and I'll say no-unused-vars,
that's going to be a 1, which is
a warning, and I'll rerun this
and now it's just warning me
instead of actually making an
error. Back to this comma-
dangle here, what is the actual
error? Sometimes people will say
that you should absolutely
always put a comma even if you
don't have another line. That's
because if you have checked
something into Git, let's say
that was my Git status right now
and then I add a new line like
dog is "Snickers," you know that
I just modified that line and
this line when I really just
wanted to add this one line.
People always put that dangling
comma on the end and I actually
generally agree with that but I
don't use it every single time
and I find it to be a bit of a
pain that it errors out on me,
so I've turned it off in my
ESLint with the comma-dangle
here. You might see this where
people pass in array instead of
just a 01 or 2, and this is
where you can pass options.
Some of these options here have
the ability to pass things as
needed props. In this case I
said no-unused-vars except when
the variable name is res, next
or error. And where is that
helpful? For me I write a lot of
node JS where I'll do something
like this, apdocget/accounts and
then I'll run a function here,
so it was like request and
response. I might be doing
something, and also it maybe
pass, next, I like to set up all
my routes like that and I might
not necessarily use res or next
but I like to have them there in
case I need to use them again.
In this case it's going to yell
at me that I haven't yet used
res or next. What I've done is
I've set them to simply just
give me a warning when I haven't
use a variable. However, if I
use res, next or anything that
starts with error then don't
worry about that at all. Now,
I'm not going to sit here and go
through every single rule in all
of ESLint and sort of explaining
what you should and shouldn't
use. What I honestly think that
you should do is start with
Airbnb and just start writing
code and over the next like
couple of days what's going to
happen is you're going to come
out, you're going to trip over
errors, you're going to say, "
Why is that error there?" Go
ahead and go to the ESLint docs,
research it, see if it's
actually a rule that makes sense
for you and your team. If it is,
make sure you keep it in your
rules. If it doesn't, take it
out of your rules or sent it to
warn instead of actual error.
A lot of times people ask me, "
Hey, Wes can I just take your
ESLint?" I think that is OK,
however I maybe even prefer that
you just start with nothing and
just learn and build your own as
you start to go through this.